buenas tardes es el momento político más
difícil que vive boris johnson por ahora
cuenta con el apoyo de su partido el
partido conservador pero lo cierto es
que algunas voces dentro de su propia
colectividad han empezado a abrir la
puerta la puerta para una posible
consulta sobre si debe seguir o no como
el jefe del partido conservador y por
ende el primer ministro como lo
mencionas el jefe del partido laborista
de oposición y los nacionalistas
escoceses han pedido que johnson
renuncia dé un paso al costado porque no
tiene la autoridad moral para seguir
liderando el país pero es poco probable
que lo haga si johnson ha pedido
disculpas hoy en el parlamento por
romper la ley que él mismo creó pero lo
cierto es que han sido unas disculpas a
medias aseguró que se trató de un evento
de trabajo cuando en el correo
electrónico de invitación enviado por
sus propios secretarios privados era
evidente que se trataba de un evento
social es clave en este momento para la
permanencia de johnson en su cargo la
investigación
pendiente que adelanta el gobierno sobre
estas fiestas